there are a lot of powerful Arguments
for atheism for instance there's the
argument
from no that's
garbage well atheists have an argument
called gosh that's even
worse no that's just
sad you know I simply can't think of any
good Arguments for atheism but
fortunately for us someone who's way
smarter than I am is on the case here's
Dr Jordan Peterson discussing Arguments
for atheism on pints with
aquinus what do you think the best
argument for atheism is
I don't think there is a good argument
for atheism see now that's what I
thought maybe I'm more smarter than I
always thought I was there is no no good
argument for atheism I don't think there
is a good argument for atheism I think
it's based on a fundamental
misunderstanding about the nature of the
world so it's just it's it's a it's what
would you say it's an illegal chess move
it's an illegal chess
move what you thought you could just
take the king out of the game because
you're an atheist and you don't know how
to
mate but there's a problem with Dr
Peterson's response the question wasn't
are there any good Arguments for atheism
of course there aren't the question was
what's the best argument for atheism
even if all the arguments for a terrible
absurd position are bad arguments you
can still point to the best of the bad
arguments so what's the best of the bad
Arguments for atheism this might this
might just show that I don't understand
you we'll get to it if I don't the best
argument for atheism what's the
best materialistic determinism is the
best argument for atheism but isn't that
a philosophical sort of assumption or
Axiom well yeah that's a problem yeah
the best of the bad Arguments for
atheism according to Jordan Peterson is
materialistic
determinism I'm not sure what he means
by materialistic determinism that would
normally be the view that what happens
in the material world is determined by
by matter and the laws of nature that
wouldn't mean that God doesn't exist you
can be a materialistic determinist about
our universe and still believe that God
exists so I'll assume that he just means
materialism materialism in this sense is
the position that the material world is
the fundamental reality everything that
happens can ultimately be explained in
terms of matter in motion now if the
material world is all there is there
obviously can't be an immaterial deity
so if we assume that materialism is true
then God doesn't exist but as Matt
pointed out that's an assumption but
isn't that a philosophical sort of
assumption or axom well yeah that's a
problem yeah if you assume at the
beginning that the material world is all
that exists and you conclude that God
can't exist because you've already
assumed that the material world is all
that exists that begging the question so
the best argument for atheism would be a
fallacy but our materialistic
determinist friends can find comfort in
the fact that according to their
worldview if their reasoning is
fallacious they were determined to
reason felci justly so atheists it's not
your fault the universe made you like
this but suppose what we really mean
when we ask what's the best argument for
atheism
is what's the most effective argument
for atheism what's the most effective
argument for
atheism here the answer isn't really an
argument it's not a fallacy it's a
manipulation tactic join our group and
you're smart don't join our group and
you're dumb atheists smart religious
people dumb a smart them dumb them no
smart we smart them
dumb if you could convince people that
they magically become the champions of
some prized virtue just by joining your
group and running around screaming Sky
daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky
daddy Sky daddy you're going to win a
lot of
converts that's why atheism took off in
the early 2000s a bunch of gullible
young people boarded The Good Ship cheap
e go boost on a one-way trip to Fantasy
Land but let's invite them to Planet
reality for a
moment falling for lowlevel manipulation
tactics and the fallacies you'd hear
about on day one of a logic class
doesn't mean you're smart patting
yourself on the back and bragging about
being champions of reason and science
doesn't make you champions of reason and
science living in an online Echo chamber
of we smart dumb gives you absolutely no
reason to think that you're smarter than
anyone else stop boasting for a while
close your eyes and think
deeply and you'll
realize I don't think there is a good
argument for atheism
[Music]